この動画のテーマは生成AIの仕組みの超初歩でございます。
ここではですね、大規模言語モデルの中身について迫っていこうと思っております。
まずですね、この図を見てください。
これがですね、入力、我が辺は猫であるというのを入れた後にですね、次のトークンに対する確率というものを計算したものです。
サイバーエージェントさんが出しているモデルの実力をですね、ここに計算して出しています。
ここでトークンというのは、情報の最小単位になっているわけでして、単語やその一部などのことがあります。
それらがですね、AIが区切った後に扱える単語みたいなわけですね。
その中にですね、例えばこういうふうな開業記号だったり、エンドブテキストというのはここで終わりという印ですよね。
そうしたものがあって、この終端、どこで文章を切るかというのも実は確率的に決まっているわけでございます。
面白いことにですね、我が辺は猫であるって来た後に名前はまだないと続くはずなんですが、名前というのは出てきていないわけでございますね。
で、実行回帰生成みたいなことをやっています。
一層クン出すために自分の出力を入力に足し直して、ある意味やっているようなことと同じです。
まず一回ですね、我が輩入って入れてですね、AIを一回通して推論させて、次の言葉は歯だなとわかる。
そしてその次にですね、我が輩入っているのをもう一回入れて、入力して、次は猫だなとわかる。
そして我が輩猫と入れてですね、もう一回AIで次のトークンが何かって確率を出して、我が輩猫でって選ばれている。
こういう風になっているわけでございます。
このようにですね、文法を出して一つ選んで、積み値を消して、そしてまた一元というのをひたすら反復しているようなイメージを持ってください。
ただ、線形代数はですね、全部を毎回計算するのではなくて、洗礼された式によってですね、出ているってことになっています。
分布から一つ選んでいるわけですが、そのやり方というのが出力の補正を決めています。
常にですね、一番確率高いものを選ぶという方法は、グリーディレコーディングというののことで、特律な名前がついています。
しかしですね、それは無難だったりするんですけども、単調でありますし、あまりうまくいかないと。
私が使っているAIの出力はですね、実際には確率に応じてサンプリングしています。
サンプリングなので、同じ入力でも出力が毎回変わるわけですね。
その振れ幅を決めるつまみが、温度パラメータ、テンパラチャーと呼ばれています。
出力のばらつきを決めるつまみですが、低いほど堅実的ですし、高いほど対応だが脱線しやすいということになっています。
気になる人はですね、Pythonの中にですね、トランスフォーマーズといったようなですね、
ライブラリというのがありますので、その中にどんな引数があるのかを調べてみてください。
なので、AIの回答が毎回違うのはですね、バグなわけではないんですね。
彼らはルールなどを元にですね、回答しているわけではないんです。
分布からの抽選、サンプリングによって揺らいでいるだけなんですね。
流暢にかけることと中身が正しいことは別物でございます。
つまり、左から一トークンずつ確定していくようなタスクをAIは解いているわけですよ。
我が輩はとか、我が輩はね、こう、で、みたいな感じですね。
彼らの基準としては、流暢な文章を必ず完成するということなんですね。
ただ、中身が正しい保証というのは全くないわけです。
ここで誤解がないように言っておきますけども、
言語系の生成AIというのは、文法のルール種であるわけでもありません。
正しいデータの集合でもありません。
単に流暢さを鍛えたモデルといえます。
文法的な目中でも、それが、出力はですね、事実かどうかは別問題です。
断定苦笑で堂々と誤る可能性があります。
なのでですね、ハルシネーションは構造上の規制なんだということを理解していただければと思います。
流暢さとかですね、AIの自信といったところに騙されてですね、
人が確かめる必要があるよというのはそういうことでございます。
ということでですね、この動画で生成AIの中身をざっと見てました。
詳細についてはですね、第3回の動画の中で様々語っていければと思います。
とりあえず、次のトークを予測するというタスクをしているんだよということ、
それから流暢にかけるということでトレーニングされたモデルであるから、
正解がかけるかどうかはまた別問題だよということを理解していただければというふうに思います。
ということで、この動画を終わります。
ご静聴ありがとうございました。
ありがとうございました。